what's up everyone it's meme review time
and you know what that means it's time
for some below average entertainment
but first i forgot
contact lenses and now i look like my
puppy
that's better let's get into the
freaking memes let's just get into it
next meme let's get a really good meme
in here let's get a really good one
hamburger ham and
hamburger hamburger is a meme now
everyone it's finally happened
congratulations
to everyone that invested in the
hamburger fast food stock market it's
finally payoff time because
hamburger is a meme hamburger
i'm going to mcdonald's do you want a
hamburger
hamburger that relatable moment
where you're part of the avengers and
thor asks i'm going to mcdonald's do you
want an
in a hamburger smash like if you can
relate to this video
right freaking now what flavor you ask
hamburger
this originated from youtube poop who
had sonic
saying hamburger thank you youtube
hamburger
my god will this reference be
seen in the sonic film it remains to be
seen
good sentence felix thank you
hamburger so why is everyone saying
hamburger
has everyone just freaking lost their
minds what is
freaking happening millennial humor is
so weird
what if you wanted to go to heaven
but god said hamburger
i think this is another existential
question that we've all asked ourselves
at one point and
another i mean what would you do
literally what would you do
i don't know what i would do i would
just say hamburgers as well probably and
hope for the best
hamburger is that a hamburger
that is a hamburger oh
whoa whoa
a hamburger hamburger
he said it
[Music]
hamburger what has happened we used to
have uganda knuckles god damn it
why the frick is hamburger a meme it's
not even
that funny of a food i can name at least
five other foods at the top of my head
chicken tequila masala what the freaking
kind of name is that
shirt uh wow sounds way funnier i love
hamburger
say it yoda oh my god who's going to say
it
it's african i'm south african uh no
accent though cause i was raised here
handbook these compilations completely
ruin the joke
because you know exactly what they're
gonna say at least if you're scrolling
through instagram or whatever
you don't know exactly what meme it's
gonna be but you you sit through a
compilation and it's like
they're i'm just waiting for them to say
hamburger
hamburger hamburger you know if it
didn't say hamburger
then i would laugh all right you need to
surprise me at least god damn it felix
why are you so salty now
huh why are you being such a hamburger
because i want to god damn it and you
can't stop me
you see what i mean you know what enough
for this i'll show you some good memes
nobody fish in the grocery store now
that's funny
come on oh you oh i'm sorry you want
more hamburger compilation memes
sorry all right sure i'll give you more
hamburger company
hamburger
okay that one was good i did like that
one
sorry hamburger i take everything back
you're so funny
i love you so much like this this is a
funny meme
he's holding it with his ass cheeks he's
dummy thick
all right guys serious question time no
more jokes
no more playing around serious question
time okay you ready to answer questions
you have three seconds to answer
all right you get either 500 euro but
you have to delete your facebook account
forever
absolute win i'll take it easy
next one okay okay i realized that one
was a little bit easy
how about this one you are very
attractive
to the opposite sex but you are
also very attracted to the same sex
and your skin is green
[Music]
food for thought okay all right i
realized these are a little bit easy
questions
i got the better one for you coming
right up you only get two seconds to
answer this one
you die all right you die
but but fortnite dies too but
god damn this is so easy just kill me
you have one second to answer
this one all right instagram dies
but reddit is always in light mode
no freaking dude luke my eyes will die
these are so sh can i get one funny
[ __ ] meme this week
jesus christ all right here we go
bowling alley memes you heard about
these
you heard about bowling alley memes
remember we were bowling as a kid and
the animation would
we made more fun than the actual [ __ ]
game nobody the bowling alley screen
when you get a strike
nobody bowling alley tv is winning again
this is a good meme thank lord thank
lord almighty nobody that bowling alley
screen when you get
legit i would have more fun looking at
the goddamn screen than playing bowling
who likes bowling anyway all right let's
get another good meme in here dank memes
kills memes faster than pewdiepie
what the freak ice
you think you're funny with your little
jokes you're not
funny you're gay and i mean that in the
best way possible
brofist if you're gay too this screen at
the bowling alley when you can't
strike i cannot i don't know about you
guys but i
kind of want to go bowling now i kind of
bowling
yes that's it
smash like if this is completely
freaking accurate
when you're an animator who gets hired
by bowling alley
i'm gonna make some weird freaking [ __ ]
who made this that's a good point
actually
if you're a bowling alley 3d model
design
creator hit me up in the comments with
the likes just so i know if you're there
nobody bowling alley screen when you get
a strike
that relatable moment even this joke the
novelty
wears off pretty quickly doesn't it
nobody the bowling alley screen when you
get a strike
three dreams are made of these who had a
man
to piss on me i changed the lyrics just
so they can't copy strike it
it's fine it's called innovation learn
what it is umg
the bowling alley screen when you get
described whatever
click loop and then play there it is
this is humor all right you stupid
millennials you stinky millennials
with your silly dummy dumb humor this is
humor right
i don't care about your obscure
hamburger
all right what have we got
damn all right did we get to see the
strike there it is
that's it 10 out of 10. we'll play
bowling
never again light skin monte
posted this clip on instagram
oh [ __ ] a rat
there's a rat there's a [ __ ]
hood n words when they see a rat i think
we can all relate
[Music]
what's he gonna do now
i take everything back god damn it
oh
damn it oh
[ __ ] no no
stop hamburger stop the goddamn
hamburger
[ __ ] i never want to see another
hamburger meaning my goddamn like
okay people are getting creative oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
hey is he gonna mine it he's gonna dare
it
come on some of these are good i'll hand
it to you guys
your little editors with your little
edits you think you're so good
a very sexy man is that ricardo
okay that's good absolute win this has
been
the last meme review ever i'm sorry i
forgot to tell you guys but
it's over i'm marry ham and i'm just
canceling all the shows
i'm sick of it i want none of it anymore
and i see you never again
bye what you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]